[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the ramsy show it's
where we help you win in your life
specifically with your money your
relationships and your work
88255 225 is the phone number that's
8825 5225 I'm Ken Coleman the
incomparable the Fantastic fabulous Jade
warshaw joins me this hour always fun
partner when we're hanging out together
partner now a little bit later in the
hour I might reveal I'll just reveal
just a little bit you have a big
milestone coming up but I don't know
whether or not I won't see I'll you can
decide if you want to tell them okay I
think you've already decided I think I
just got the message so I'll hold on to
that but it's exciting we're a
dog all right we'll see we'll see if I
can get her to tell you but she's
awesome love hanging out with Jaden
she's going to take your money questions
I'll chime in I'll take any work related
questions let's get that bigger shovel
going how do I make more money and Jade
will chime in on those as well so let's
go America triple
8825 5225 Kimberly starts us off this
hour in Charlotte North Carolina
Kimberly how can we
help hi thank you so much for taking my
my call you bet um I moved down here
about a year ago I'm a a full-time
student adult student uh I'm also a
full-time server um and I moved down
here a year ago from Jersey um to
because my mom had gotten sick and I
couldn't take care of her on my own and
my sister agreed to to help out if I
moved down here
um I was originally planning on going to
grad school and continue on in order to
get a job with my degree um but that's
no longer an option because now I'm
caring for my mom so the only experience
I have is serving in restaurant
throughout that I worked my way through
college and that's not paying the bills
and that's not a paying the bills enough
for to for to support myself as well as
my mom um and my sister said that she
can't handle it so she said she's
leaving at the end of the lease oh and
I'm going to be on my own and I graduate
this spring and I have no idea what job
I can get and what what are you
graduating with what degree philosophy
and religion and which direction were
you going because you just said that I
was planning to do this and now I can't
so where was that going to play out what
was the
goal well I was interested in I did
really well at school and I was
approached by the government for um
Foreign Service Officer and policy and
peacemaking which really interested me
um I always wanted to be the or or a
philosopher growing up um and then but
before that my plans was to go into uh
Professor University Professor okay uh
which requires a master and a doctorate
now okay but um but I think you've
limited yourself and that's what I want
to do I want to talk about what all you
can do so you are going to finish with
this degree in May is that correct yes
so you got the bachelor's what are you
making as a waitress what are you
serving how much you
making
nothing well it's not nothing where are
you working how much you making we got
to walk through this you got to give me
some numberb so we can get
somewhere um I'm probably bringing home
around 700 a week okay and where you
just working at a chain restaurant
what's going on it's a fine dining
Steakhouse oh good okay so you're
getting some good tips just it's just
you're limited in what you can do there
is what you're telling us right all
right so here's the deal you've got a
college degree and I don't care if it's
in full philosophy or biology doesn't
matter with that bachelor's degree you
have the option to teach now you may not
be able to teach on the higher ed level
but you can teach yes or
no yes and I looked at I'm sorry go I'm
sorry I I cut you off but here's here's
what I wanted to say you can
teach and and you can teach a lot of
different topics and it and it it
actually gets you on that path may not
be the destination that you were aiming
at but but teaching is at least that
love that idea that you had initially so
what's keeping you from pursuing that
cuz there are teachers that are dropping
out all the time school systems need
teachers you're going to have a degree
and you're going to make more money so
what's keeping you from doing that well
I was looking at that path I was looking
at that path and uh for uh Catholic
School teaching high school Catholic
School teaching I don't need to be
certified by the state right
to do that so I started contacting uh
the dasis here in Charlotte um and got
some information interviews about what
that would entail so that is a possible
path that I am pursuing what is the
financial look Outlook though what is
what's the pay range not just limiting
ourselves to the Catholic schools what's
that look like for you right well the
Catholic schools is actually a higher
pay range in the public school so what
would that range be between 60 and 80 to
start great
so I want to bring Jade in really quick
here uh Jade I'd like to know Kimberly
what the shortfall is going to be if CIS
is backing out so she's not helping with
rent presumably what is the shortfall
that you have to be able to take care of
your of your student loan payment plus
all of your living expenses can you walk
Jade through that yeah what what tell me
more about your financials obviously we
know you're making around 2,800 a month
uh what's the Le What's the total uh
rent or lease payment that you that
you'll be taking on
so there I wouldn't be able to stay at
the house it would be um it's 2,300 for
the house okay so have you started
actively looking for other
places yes so when I moved down here it
cost me 5,000 to move down here so that
put me into more debt obviously okay so
okay and that's on a credit
card yes okay keep going keep running
out the story so my my total debt now I
have about 10,000 in debt on credit card
okay 10K on credit cards my student my
student loans are going to kick in and I
have well they probably won't kick in
for another eight or nine months but um
it'll be about 22,000 in total for okay
anything else cars loans and then I have
5,000 left on my car okay good okay um
what when you're looking out there for
apartments what do you think you can get
and can you get another roommate can you
get something cheaper with a roommate
that would be my thing one I'm not
looking for the $2,300 apartment I'm
looking for the $1,800 apartment if
possible something I can share with
somebody that you know is reliable and
dependable um because what I'm hoping to
get you to is an apartment that you
could afford on your own in case the
roommate moves out but you've got a
roommate there as a safety net so that
you can save some money so that's what
we're looking for um and I you know
listening to what you said to Ken I just
kind of want to know what the timeline
is on this Catholic School thing because
your problem is an income problem that's
the the true issue here and you know
I've said this before and I'll say it
again anything that's making more than
what you're making now anything you can
add to that is a plus right now even if
it's not you know it might take several
months for this Catholic School thing to
shake out but if there's anything that
you can add to what you're doing now to
to solve this income problem that's
short term that's right then do it
Kimberly I want to add to that I I you
can we're going to give you every dollar
uh Jade let's give her something here in
about 10 seconds but Kimberly listen
with that degree and a 3.7 unemployment
rate in the United States and Charlotte
is a very good Market you are just using
that degree to do whatever you need to
do to get a a foot into this debt kick
it out and then we make the progress but
I would be teaching I'd be going the
direction you want to go but you've got
to make more money Jade what can we give
her let's give her every dollar matter
of fact let's set her up with Financial
Peace University that whole Ramsey plus
bundle so she can have everything she
needs Kimberly follow the steps you got
this you can do this this is the Ramsey
[Music]
show if you're like most people your
home is your most valuable asset and
when you want to make improvements it
can feel like everything costs too much
or takes too long but something as
simple as custom window coverings from
blinds Doom
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to get
up to 45% off that's blinds.com rules
and restrictions May
[Music]
apply
all right who need some help out there
you're just going I'm I'm not where I
want to be I'm not where I want to be
with my money I'm not where I want to be
in my relationships I'm not where I want
to be in my professional Journey if
that's you no shame in your game number
one and number two
we'd love to help we been Jade warshaw
my colleague co-host and friend and I'm
Ken Coleman or Ramsey personalities and
we're here for you this is a this is a
listener of viewer show we are here for
you we take your questions
8825 5225
8825 5225 let's go to Detroit now
Kendall is there Kendall how can we
help hi nice to talk with you today you
too what's going on um so I just
graduated medical school about a half a
year ago
congrats thank you um so about three and
a half years left obviously residency
salary is about 60,000 I have about 220
in student debt um but no other debt in
my life um so my plan is like you know I
can't pay off my debt while I'm a
resident I don't make enough but when I
graduate I was going to live off of like
40,000 pay off my debt in two years but
my question is I don't have like any
money Sav for retirement and I'll be 33
when I start making six figures so
should I prioritize paying off my debt
or should I start saving more for
retirement well Jay's going to help you
on that but I'm just real curious what
do you think that starting salary is and
what do you think the range is maybe in
the first couple
years uh 270 to 300 most likely Jade you
can do something with that can't you
coach listen I'm excited for you um
thank you excited too should be I'm I'm
I'm excited for you you know you've got
this big milestone you know coming up
you've got three and a half years left
of med school so that's that's cool so
luckily you came out of this with only
20,000 of student loans can I just
quickly ask 2 220 what 220 I caught that
one listen I'm glad I asked cuz I was
like how in the world would you do that
all right so you've got 220 of student
loans nothing else right yes nothing
else okay and we've got a couple more
years of 60 ,000 salary 60 to 80 or just
60 yeah like 60 to 70 probably okay um
yeah I I'm with you uh they're not going
to become due until after you graduate
right and then you've got well are they
going to be does it does your residency
count for that or is it
separate so they're on I'm on an income
based rep payment plan and also the save
plan so okay like typically they gain
$1,000 a month of Interest but the th
those two plans allow me to um pay 233
and the government um pays the rest of
the interest so they're not going to
grow in residency and I only have to pay
233 a month but when I graduate that'll
change okay okay got it um you know I
would try to pay as much as you can with
the salary that you have I mean that's
all that you can do but what I really
want to
address is the fact that you said that
you're only 33 years old and you'll be
33 when it's time to retire or when it's
time to start saving for retirement you
don't want to be behind and I whenever I
hear that I kind of just want to let
people know like I've been there and you
know when my husband and I were paying
off our student loan debt which was
about
280,000 you know we didn't finish that
until we were around your age 33 uh
pregnant with my my son and we hadn't
started investing at all and I kind of
want you to understand that you're going
to be okay so let's just pretend I I
love doing the investment calculator so
let's let's just play around here how
how old are you can I ask yeah I'm 29
right now oh my goodness you're 29 so
let's just say I'm going to plug this in
we have a really cool investment
calculator and I'm just going to say
let's pretend you're 29 years old now
let's pretend that you plan to retire at
age 62 let's just say that um and you
have zero in retirement now
right and let's just say because you're
let's say because you're saving for a
home you're not investing the whole 15%
we would advise when the time comes so
let's say you're investing 10% so $2,700
a month Fair are you tracking with me
yep okay so we're doing 2700 I'm
plugging that in and let's just be very
conservative and saying 8% annualized
rate of return let's calculate that and
see what that'll be so when the time
comes you'll have over $5
million oh okay $5 million
yeah that's a lot yeah I think you're
going to be all
right I think you're GNA be just fine so
that's that's what I want you to leave
here with is all right I've got time I'm
work you know I'm doing the MD thing I'm
paying as much as I can once I hit this
salary I'll be able to knock out
whatever remains I'll save up 3 to six
months of expenses in baby step three
and by then like I said you might be
wanting to save for a down payment too
and that's baby step 3B and that comes
before you started investing so you've
got time and you might start to do baby
step 3B and baby step 4 which is
investing 15% at the same time whatever
you choose there you're going to be fine
$5 million that makes me sleep a lot
better at night K and those numbers and
and by the way Kendall those numbers are
going to be way bigger than that she was
just going real conservative here
because that's if you never make any
more money like you're starting salary
what two years you pay off your debt
then you got your emergency fund after
that you save for a house let's just say
you don't start in investing until
36 again not an issue because of the
amount of money that your 15% represents
and the compound interest is insane okay
so you don't have to worry about that
that's the point I don't that's the
whole thing that you called about you're
not too late you aren't going to be
destitute you're going to be very very
wealthy is it just you Kendall right now
it's just me I'm still I'm still uh
figuring that out yeah yeah but so
that's a Point Jade that doesn't take
into account a double income oh by the
way you know what else it doesn't take
into account all the money you're going
to make on a house cuz you're going to
put a really big chunk down and you're
going to pay it off and so you're going
to have a pay for house when you retire
as well I I got to tell you Kendall i'
be shocked if you don't do what we tell
you to do if you're not in the 10
million range by the time you're
65 the shocked that's incredible I'm not
making that up am I security yeah I I
don't think that's a stretch no I don't
think that's a stretch you know so so
you've got this you got it thank you
yeah I really appreciate it follow the
plan hey do you have any of our products
you got any books or anything things
that you kind of lean
on I don't my sister went through your
program um and she normally just like
talks to me about all of this kind of
stuff but I don't have any I want to
give you something Jade let's give her
something to kind of cement this so that
she can see the process for sure Total
Money Makeover yeah Total Money Makeover
and hey I want you to head to every
doll.com and I want you to pick up every
dollar premium and it it'll give you $15
off and what I love about every dollar
premium is you can kind of the same way
that I plugged in your numbers and gave
you that snapshot of what your investing
future could look like we've got a
financial road map Planner on there that
you can plug in all sorts of numbers to
figure out where you want to be and
where you're going to meet certain
Milestones so you can plug in numbers to
figure out how long it would take you to
save 3 to six months of expenses or how
long it would take you to save up for a
home those sorts of things so um we'll
make sure you have that and I think
she's all said kall you're a rockar uh
Okay Jade we got about a minute here we
got new people coming in all the time so
I think it's really good to revisit what
is a really sensible question yes and
that is I've got all this debt and if it
takes me six years or five years or four
years to pay it off I'm so far behind
the eightball in investing why do we
teach that the way we do that we clear
debt first before we invest explain that
to newcomers who might still be going ah
ah really I mean there's a lot of
reasons a lot of good reasons the first
reason is your income is your biggest
wealth building tool like that's a Dave
Ramsey classic quote right there you
need your income available in order to
be able to invest it and for most of us
we're living paycheck to paycheck like
we don't have any money left at the end
of the month but after we've paid our
bills our car note we've got groceries
we paid the Kids Daycare most of us
don't feel like we have that breathing
room because we have so many debts and
bills so the first step is to clear that
out so so you get your money back in
your budget and then you save up 3 to 6
months because if you don't save first
and you start investing right away if an
emergency comes you start pulling from
your retirement or you start using
credit cards and you go back into debt
so you pay off the debt you build up the
savings and then and only then we start
investing and that's the way it works if
you start doing it out of order you
start messing yourself up Ken and you
just proved it once you start that
investing compound interest becomes your
best pal and so it can work you're not
too late trust the process it works
we're so glad you've joined us she's
Jade warshaw I'm Ken Coleman this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
be
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home buyer Edge from Churchill gives you
an advantage over the other guys go to
Churchill mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
[Applause]
more welcome back to the Ramsey show I'm
Ken Coleman Jade warshaw joins me we're
here for you America the phone number
is8
[Music]
825-5222
55225 let's go to the Big Apple New York
New York I'm heading there tomorrow
night Jack how can we help hey guys how
you doing good what's going on hey um
yeah so I uh am actually pretty happy
with the kind of career that I have but
I'm hitting an income ceiling um pretty
seriously this past year and I'm a
little bit lost on how to move forward
and raise that you know I kind of delve
into delved into you guys' whole program
like last week I kind of binged and um I
actually paid off um all my credit card
debt last week nice it wasn't it wasn't
that much it was just 6K but I had some
savings so I just went ahead and did it
fantastic Jack how'd that feel it was
great it was amazing and it's just like
yeah now I'm just kind of you know I put
that thousand dollar aside as well great
good so I'm just yeah I'm just kind of
trying to figure out how to get the
income up because you know the the Big
Apple ain't cheap no it's not it is not
I like to visit I would not live there
um and I I feel you on that okay let's
let's dig into this so what profession
are you in and what is your
income um I'm in the interior decorating
and design business okay and then I'm
also a I'm also an oil painter as well
so I get a little bit of my income from
Selling paintings to okay that's awesome
what's your income um I this year I made
85k okay and are what's your living
situation an
apartment yeah I live in an apartment
alone where you're not on Manhattan I
was going to say it's not I am in
Manhattan I got very lucky I'm rent
stabilized oh wow lucky ducky what is
your rent uh it's 19900 wow that's
pretty good I mean I'm actually shocked
Jack I'm really it's I've been here a
while so that's because the kind of
feels you get when you stick around
that's awesome good for you all right so
um I'm not as familiar with the field
but I don't have to be so I need to dig
in here and when you say you've hit that
lid I think that's a great way of
describing that is that because of
qualification or is it because of
Association and what I mean by that is
the company you're in right now there's
just not a lot of opportunity for growth
if any at all explain to me what's the
lid yeah so I actually um so there are
kind of two branches of the of where I
get my income in the interior design
business okay I'm in the Union as a
decorator so that's a 60 an hour you
know set wage right or set hourly I'm
sorry sure um and then I also Garner
freelance work on my own which I
actually charge much more for but it's
much more inconsistent and I'm I have
like three or four maybe five clients a
year that I do Interiors for mostly like
restaurants in the city um So based on
your time do those gigs pay a whole lot
better I know you can charge more way
better way better all right so
and we know that you said at the start
of the call that you love the industry
so you want to be I love it yeah well
let me tell you something the Union and
and don't take this as a political
statement I'm not making a political
statement uh but in this case the union
situation for you is the lit you're just
not going to get a bump in pay unless
the union fights and then that goes up
and so what you've got to do here is I
hate to oversimplify this Jack but this
is about good oldfashioned connections
and hustle and get the word out because
you've proven you've done it on some
level right now we just got to say this
is the this is the play It's almost like
getting a blank sheet of paper and you
get a loone you get quiet and you go
what do I have to do to double and
triple and list for heck of it quadruple
the amount of what you're calling
freelance work that's the exercise and
I'm going to tell you what's going to
come down to you going back to those
restaurants that you did work for and
say hey would you be willing to make a
referral for me do you know anybody have
you had a conversation that I could do
some work for uh you are every Square
second of the day when you're not
engaged in work you're going who do I
need to connect with this week who do I
need to connect with next week that's
not what I'm doing right now yeah I
think I think you're focused on the
wrong lid to Ken's point I think you're
thinking about control that my hourly
wage but you you're part of this Union
but I'm looking at this I'm going oh my
gosh this is Limitless like as long as
you know how to do the thing and people
have used you out there in the in the
Wild on your own right that is
invaluable my goal would be I want to
get away from this union job and I want
to be starting my own thing and I want
my new problem to be I have so many
people coming to me I only have 24 hours
in the day I need to start hiring some
folks right that's really where we're
going I guess I guess my mindset lately
has just been I'm trying to kind of save
my butt with the you know more steady
union pay like as a just a steady
income um well but Jack Jack let me tell
you what I would do if I were you okay
we're going to get real real okay I
would keep the Union Gig and you need to
relax you got your steady you don't have
to stop it today you don't need to worry
about steady you've got the steady so
now you have to say Okay so so so you're
in Manhattan um are there a couple of
restaurants or social places coffee
shops or whatever that you frequent give
me a little bit of latitude a tons
gotcha and are there wealthy people that
also frequent these joints okay all
right and Jack do you have a winning
personality uh yes yes you do I was
going to say yes yes so Jack I'm
starting to talk to people and and and
do you know what the easiest way to get
someone to ask you about what you do has
anybody ever told you this Jack what do
you think the answer is I have no idea
it's just great you know what you do you
start talking to somebody you go what do
you do and you be super interested in
them Jade what do you do and Jade starts
talking about me and I need to be so
passionately enthusiastic about what
Jade's telling me that at some point if
she's not a sick human being and she's
not and she's going to say to me Ken
what do you do and then I go I'm an
interior decorator I work for the union
but I got to tell you I've just really
enjoyed I did this restaurant over there
on 47th and blah blah blah well you know
my friend is looking for somebody to
redo his restaurant because he just
start yeah or some sweet old lady who's
got eight strands of pearls around her
neck in Manhattan goes I like to redo my
bathroom or whatever and all of a sudden
Jack we got deals I know that's you
understand what I'm saying so Jack I do
this is about you connecting and the
more you connect and you share and you
show your work you ought to create a
Facebook page by the end of tonight
because it's free you ought to get an
Instagram account up tonight because
it's free do you have all that Jack yeah
I I do have a website and Instagram for
my decorating business guess what it's
one click of a button to share with
somebody Hey listen if you'd like to
redo your town home uh I'd like to come
by sometime next week let's take a look
I'll give you a couple quotes no cost no
no pressure and then the sweet old lady
goes and then she does it and then she
goes Jack I got to tell you about Ethel
and next thing you know you've got all
these big you know Blue Blood Upper
Echelon New Yorkers paying you premium
rate Jack I know that's listen Jack
slide it in my DMs cuz I want to see
what type of work you do cuz you never
know somebody wow that's that's the
first time that's happened I've never
heard that Jack she may be getting
something into you she may have a
project for you I know people that know
people is all I'm saying so I might just
slide it on in there everybody needs a
bathroom redone everybody needs a
bathroom promise you right now Jack all
right now we've had some fun with this
but I'm actually as serious as a heart
attack that is that is the strategy for
you that is the bridge from where you
are today to where you want to be
financially and here's how this works
Jack you do what Jade and I was were
just telling you to do there's GNA come
a day where you replace all of that
Union income with the side hustle income
and that's when you say bye-bye Union
and you start doing the project that you
want to do and you now go from 80 to 160
to 320 that's right I mean dude if I'm
an interior decorator the place I want
to be is the Big Apple do Spreading the
News Jack is designing today that's
right come on Jack
I want to there it is you left me
hanging kid oh sorry well I was getting
nervous it was starting to go up a
little bit I hadn't warmed up
Jack you got it yeah I got it thanks
guys I app busy hang on the line I'm
going to give you my number one
bestselling book called The Proximity
principle which says this if I'm around
the right people Jade and I'm in the
right places opportunity finds me it's
that simple Jack and oh by the way hang
on Jade wants a 20% discount on her uh
her new sunro we'll see how that goes
this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey guys ramsy Solutions started
small and grew fast because of that
rapid growth there were times when our
systems slowed us down that's why we
switched to netsuite it works for us and
it'll help your business too whether
you're starting on a card table like I
did or you're well on your way to
becoming a multi-million dollar Company
netw Suite can scale with you and help
you communicate and plan better because
you know your day-to-day up and down and
sideways but accounting analytics and
supply chain are on another level so
maybe you're just not techsavvy that can
be okay net Suite will help at your
speed and whatever your situation more
than
37,000 companies use netw Suite to know
their numbers and their business better
so check out netw Suite today and find
out how they can help you become the
business you want to be 5 or 30 years
from now and right now you can download
netsuite's free kpi checklist designed
to give you consistently excellent
performance at netsuite.com Ramsey
that's netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
the Ramsey Show continues I'm Ken
Coleman Jade warshaw joins me we are
here for you America taking your money
questions your work related
questions8 825 5225 825 5225 let's stay
local Nashville Tennessee is where Yang
joins us how can we help yeah hey um
quick question um so I'm in a 401k
currently um and it's set to aggressive
it's in a cookie cutter fund and I was
wondering if I should just leave it
alone and let it let it kind of do its
thing or if I should just actively
manage it
myself so the 401ks is through your job
and it kind of has I'm guessing like
three three knobs you can choose for it
right so it has like
conservative moderate and then
aggressive I am 25 so or you have the
option is it within the same 401K that
you can choose the actual
funds yes so I can actually go in there
and it won't give me every single fund
you know in the in the stock market but
I can um actively kind of manage it uh
myself yeah I mean wonder what else what
you guys were thinking I would choose
the funds I would go in and I would try
to find one that's you know uh growth
growth and income aggressive growth and
international and I would split my
contribution equally over those four
types so that you kind of have your
money divided out and then from there on
I'd you know set it and forget
it okay and I I think that's going to be
a little better than to just choose
aggressive you know cuz you don't really
know you can't really look and see what
the funds are and how you know what's
what's part of that mix right um so it
actually will list out kind of uh what's
in there so it has um a lot of the
things that you stated for but it's also
in um like the total stock market growth
and then um stable and then it has
international funds but I also so I
manage um about
45,000 of in my own portfolio uh that I
manag myself my dividend
and then I have a little over
30,000 um in the uh the 401K and then I
have about 55 and change in
cash okay yeah if if if I'm you I'm not
going to turn that aggressive knob I'm
going to pick the funds myself ac across
that mix of four um and my question to
you
is what percentage are you investing
right
now so right now per my the budgeting
method that I'm using um I have
30% invested uh I have 7% of that going
toward my uh
401K because my company matches just up
to that match okay and
then and then you're not going over to a
Roth IRA after that because that's what
I would suggest i' I'd invest in the
401K up to the match and then I'd go
over and if I still had money I would
max out a Roth IRA and if I still had
money then I'd go back to the 401K and
I'd Max that out and if I still had
money if I had an HSA I'd probably go to
that next and if I still had money then
I'd go in and probably go go into a
brokerage assuming you're single that is
um so I am married um and I think I
can't do like the way that it's set up
is really weird um so it's a 401k but
within it it takes out after taxes so
it's like a Roth but it's a 401k yeah
you can have a Roth
401k okay because they weren't
explaining it very well and I was like
so so in that case in that case since
you do have a Roth 401k I would Max that
out first completely you've got the
match it's Roth that's amazing so maxed
out that Roth 401k first then you know
you and your wife are both ma is her
situation the same or is hers just a
traditional match traditional
401K so she's a teacher um so I believe
it comes out automatic yes so it's
already automatic with mine so let me
say this in a way that's not confusing
do you know um with your wife's is it
how much are they pulling out of her
paycheck each time what percentage
they're they're pulling 5% I believe if
I did the calculations correctly okay so
you're investing far more than we would
say I'm
assuming I'm just going to assume that
you haven't paid off your house yet or
have you I have not okay technically
until you've paid off your house we
would suggest that you're only investing
15% of your combined incomes right and
so we would say in your situation with
you and your wife we would say the 5%
that she has you can kind of just treat
that as as gravy or you could you could
treat it as half the amount so maybe
2.5% like you know don't treat it as the
whole amount because you don't get to
really choose what it's invested in and
so we want to invest as much of our
money as we can in things that we're
choosing so for that I would say the
first the first route you're going with
you guys's entire 15% is you maxing out
that Roth 401k that's the best
investment that you vehicle that you
guys have got I wouldn't invest anything
above the 5% into her 403b or whatever
it is I would then next go to both of
you maxing out a Roth IRA both of you
and then after that if there's money I
probably you know her 403b might be fine
but I might still go to another
investment vehicle depending on on what
that's invested and what you've seen the
rate of return is on that
403b okay and if you've seen that it's
good or normal you know then you can Max
that out but yeah that's what I would do
in your
situation okay perfect um because yeah
we're using the
503020 uh method and we kind of do it
separately and then we have the way that
accounts are set up I'll just take um
you know the 30% from her after the you
know the traditional B and K and all
that from her side yeah and then I'll
use all that and kind of break down my
um my budget and for both of us really I
mean the fact is and I'm not mad at it
we have different ideologies as far as
maybe how to budget how to combine the
finances but hopefully you know you'll
you have a you know you'll respect my
view on the the investing and maybe
you'll consider it I'm not going to try
to like shift your whole Bedrock here in
this conversation cuz I don't think that
you're here for
that I I love uh I watch y'all show a
lot and I respect um and love all
y'all's opinions okay I kind of formed
um what I've been doing yeah
so listen I'm not mad at it yeah
absolutely you're on a good path he's
trying to get he's getting gathering
information and doing what he thinks is
best for his his family and you know I
was he sounds like a guy who really
understands it but it it makes me
nervous and I want you to address this
MH and said nervous metaphorically that
he's managing his own retirement account
401K makes me a little nervous let's
talk about that you know I I I spoke to
Dave recently somewhat recently about
that because we did a a rapid fire on
baby steps four five and six right four
four is investing 15% five is investing
or setting aside for kids college and of
course six is paying off the house and
so I said to Dave I said listen you know
most people they have their 401k and and
similar to what uh uh young said you can
either kind of choose the one of three
knobs like conservative mediocre and
then aggressive or you can go in and
choose the funds and I said to Dave I
said do you really need um a
professional to help you just pick out
your 401K and he was like not
necessarily but if you're going beyond
that and which which all of us will and
should then you do want to work with
that professional because you don't want
to to just go out you know to just open
up Charles Schwab and just be out there
on your own and I'm G to pick a fund
what do you what do you know you know
that's like me being like you know what
I think I have a cavity let me go in
here and see what I can do right right
right I think you make a great point and
what we and what we teach folks is that
you need to understand it so when we
talk about a smart Vestor Pro and we
mentioned them on our on the website and
they are professionals that again
they're independent they're on their own
but we recommend these folks because
they believe in the process that we
teach the reason that matters is is I
sat down we have our annual meeting
Stacy and I just did it last week M and
I'm co-hosting this show done this for
years and I still have good questions
that I need answers to and and and
they're simple sometimes right and um I
need to understand every move we're
making but I need guidance to figure out
what move to make and then I understand
it to the point where I always make the
decision Stacey and I both go all right
hey John explain this to me or what
about this I get all the explanation
when I understand it now I'm in total
control of making the decision and
that's why the expert the real Pro comes
into play here they know about stuff we
don't know about they have better
strategies they have experience and
that's why we like to do that but young
I mean listen you're you're not in bad
shape at all thank you for the call very
thoughtful stuff great hour Jade warshaw
always fun partner to hang with you
thanks to James Childs and the crew for
keeping us on the air and thank you
America for watching this is the ramsy
show
[Music]
a
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the Ramsey Show to
where we help you win specifically with
your money your work and your
relationships all those go together to
live that meaningful life to have the
life that you've dreamed of 88255 225 is
the phone number I'm Ken Coleman Jade
warshaw joins me and we are here for you
this hour
88255 225 let's get it started right out
of the gate with Milwaukee Wisconsin is
where Emily is Emily how can we
help hi thanks for having me on you guys
are really awesome to listen to it's
been great well thank you what's going
on I had a question um my husband and I
uh We've we've been together for 12
years we're High School sweethearts
we've been married it'll be two years in
June
okay uh just only question that I have
is um we I guess like 2021 I bought a
house uh we didn't have him on it cuz
his my mom kind of helped and uh said
you know just have you on it because
your credit score is higher than his if
his is lower you're going to get like a
lower loan so and you weren't married
yet right no we were engaged and now I
see that was dumb later like cuz didn't
work out right we agree we agree with
Mom I agree with Mom on that oh okay all
right um but so now we now
um now when I had like my uh I had to
pay property taxes I'm like oh it's like
in my old name it's just me should I add
him to the deed is that going to affect
anything if if something like happens
would it go to him because I talked to
my property manager lady that's in not
property manager mortgage lady and she
said that it's a marriage so if anything
happens to go to him but would it matter
if he's on the deed or not since we're
married now I would definitely add him
to the deed um it makes him an owner cuz
right now he doesn't own it it's he's
not an owner of your house only you are
um and so for that reason and I kind of
flipped the script in my mind I'm like
if if I met Sam and he had a house and I
was like Hey can can you put me on the
deed and he said no that would
definitely affect me it would affect him
cuz he'd be on the moon but it would
I believe that you would smack him right
upside the head um so just I think for
you guys to really feel like one unit
and one uh I would definitely add him to
the deed um and then it does strike up a
bigger conversation of just you
know with what did you say you talk to a
lawyer or real estate about
this uh her mortgage professional
professional morgage person yeah yeah
she says if I were to do that I would
have to go to the rewrite the deed and
it cost maybe uh some money to do that
but she's like you really don't need to
do that because it's Mar property so he
has half true I just wasn't sure I you
know I would put his name on it um I'm
the type of person I just like stuff to
be sealed tight I got I want both
people's names on the deed I'm I have a
will and in the will everything is
specific so if you don't have that now
that you're married for sure everybody
needs a will but now that you're married
for sure the two of you need to get a
will um separate that lists what each
other wants and you both need to make
sure you have life insurance those are
the three things that are really
important uh when you join life and join
finances and they just three things that
really say listen I love you and I want
to love you well in in those
ways Emily I and we actually just got
term life
insurance talk was really helpful oh
good job I completely agree with Jade I
if you're looking for what we think
that's it and uh it's just the right way
to do it and and it's it's not that
expensive so you know it's this is not
one of those convenience issues you just
never know here's the other thing you
never know what the state legislator is
going to do are you keeping up with that
the will and the deed will take care of
all of this and get it get it snapped up
nice and tight ah Briana if I got that
right and Superior Wisconsin how can we
help hi thank you for having me you bet
did I say your name right yes you did oh
I'm Hooked on Phonics it's very very
exciting thank you thank you for letting
me know that how can we help
today um so I'm just trying so I'm 20
years old and I'm trying to find the
best way possible that I can um pay off
my debt and hopefully encourage my
boyfriend to do the same who let's start
with just you that's two different calls
that is that is but look I'm glad that
you're looking out for your guy as well
um yes tell us a little about your
situation um so like I said I'm 20 I
ended up taking out a credit card and a
loan right after high school so probably
a year after high school so I was
19 pretty much my whole childhood my
parents have kind of were like you know
being an adult you take out credit cards
you take out loans and I kind of thought
that that's what you had to do to dump
start your life as an adult you're not
alone walk us uh give Jade your your
your smallest to largest debts can you
walk us through all those one at a time
smallest to largest um so I have two um
Bank credit cards so um the first one
payoff is $500 I was my first one that I
took out I have a second credit card
that is $300 to pay off and then I have
um a store credit card that is also $300
to pay off okay what about this other
loan um so I have a fourwheeler loan
that I ended up taking out uh when I was
19 so a little over a year ago um it was
$3500 I think with um maybe a four six%
interest rate I haven't checked it um is
it still $3,500 or have you paid it down
um it's so my boyfriend actually ended
up taking out the loan himself um but I
my parents were telling me if you really
want to help your credit out you should
probably move that four-wheeler loan on
to your name so when we did move it over
it ended up uh we uh we ended up having
to pay the full amount and start from
scratch oh wonderful advice way to go
Mom Dad come on now okay so now you've
got the $3,500 for wheeler it's back in
your name where it
started you've got the two credit cards
for 300 and the credit card for 500 is
there anything else student loans
cars hopefully um I do not have any
student loans or cars luckily my parents
uh bought me a nice car when I was in
high school so I still drive that is it
paid off with it um or are they making
payments for you they're the one that
are they're the ones that are making
payments for me um okay I want to I'm
going to ask more about that um do you
know what the car is worth by the way
I'm just
curious um it's a 2016 Outback so it's
probably I think I checked it's probably
around the six to $8,000 Mark okay on
Kelly Blue Book okay especially with the
miles on
it okay here's the thing um you've got a
lot of debt to pay off it's not a lot
you know you're 20 years old but it's a
lot for a 20-year-old what are you
earning real quick just tell me what you
make every month so
I take home about 22 to
$2500 a month okay so all right tell you
what brown and we're running up against
a break and I want Jade to be able to
walk you through how to knock this out
so we got to do a quick commercial break
when we come back it's Jade and Briana
and we're going to show her how she gets
out of this debt you going learn pretty
quickly so don't move this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
hey guys you know this but I'll say it
anyway college is freaking expensive and
student loans are out of control the
average private student loan debt in
2023 was
$55,000 so if you're in over your head
with private student loan debt don't
beat yourself up look we've all made
mistakes with money in the past what
matters is doing something about it now
so if you're in distress with private
student loans that's private not federal
student loans call why refi y refi
refinances defaulted private student
loans that other places won't touch and
gives you a custom loan built for you
based on your ability to pay to learn
more about this custom refinancing
option call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman and Jade warshaw joins me this
hour thrilled to have you with us the
phone number to jump in Isle
5225 our question of the day is brought
to you by neighborly your hub for Home
Services winter is rougher in some areas
of the country than others but there are
things that make sense to do no matter
where you live oh that's right oh yeah
James all right no it's okay but this is
live radio and I'm okay with it thank
James are fearless leader reminded me we
still have bana on the line where would
we be without you James well someone
reminded me to remind you so it wasn't
even me probably in the ditch that we
would drive the truck right into the
ditch okay so we'll skip the neighborly
question of the day for right now we'll
get back to it I know you all love to
hear me read uh but uh here's where we
were okay so let me set us up James
thank you for reminding me or Austin or
whoever um okay so Briana called in yes
and she doesn't have a ton of debt I
think I heard a a 500 a 500 and a 300
some credit cards not a lot very low and
then she's got a $3,500 uh four-wheeler
loan and I think that's it and so yeah
we started talking about her income
right so now Jay's going to walk her
through uh how she's going to pay this
debt off so Briana are you still
there yep all right okay take it away
Jade okay so you had just told us that
you're making 2500 a month
correct yep okay good um and what's your
living situation you're living with the
boyfriend or no yep okay I'm living with
them and you guys are splint splitting
rent or does he like own a house or
something um so we live in what they
call uh luxury Flats um we're actually
paying pretty cheap rent in our area so
uh separately we're paying uh six uh 600
a month okay so that's pretty cheap okay
yep so in total it's um almost $1,200
for a studio okay great so you're not
like overly extended on your um on your
rent per se um yep I would like if it
was six here's the thing $600 in normal
life is great uh when you're making 2500
it's it's a little more right so the The
Cure The Cure here is you're not going
to find anything cheaper than 600 so
you've got to get your income up for
more reasons than just the rent also so
that you can uh start making Headway on
paying off this debt what is your what's
the job because I want Ken to jump in
here because I can tell you right now
the formula is find more work so that
you can increase your income so that you
can pay off these debts quickly because
at the end of the month after you've
paid your bills uh I don't know why I
want to say your name wrong Briana after
you've paid your bills after you've
bought groceries after you've done the
things that you need to do how much
money do you have left
over um so for the week I probably have
around 250 250 each week each week yep
okay y so right now I mean that's not
actually that's not bad you can take
that you should be done with you know
one and a half one to one and three4 of
the credit cards right cuz it's two $300
ones so you could have the majority of
both of those paid off this month and
then next month you'll pay off the other
credit card and then you just walk on
down the line and it's going to take you
uh six seven months to pay off the loan
that you have and then technically
you're out of debt but then what I want
you to start thinking about real quickly
is what it looks like cuz I you know
your parents can do what they want to do
but I hate that they're in debt on your
account on your at your expense so you
might want to ask them about listen what
are your plans to to paying off this car
or I'd like to be in a situation where
I'm not causing you to be in in debt on
my behalf and figure out what that looks
like carwise maybe you buy them out and
you're just done with it and now you own
the car outright but I would be looking
into that since you've said you know I'm
here I am I'm on my own and if you're on
your own then they don't need to be in
debt for you that's just Jade's two
cents Ken take it away I actually agree
with that I think it's time for you to
grow up up and it's a very nice gesture
that they made but they're not making
good financial decisions I mean they're
the ones that recommended you get a
four-wheeler or or Finance the
four-wheel or whatever that nonsense was
so I agree with Jade on that um let's
talk about the bigger shovel this is the
term that Dave has kind of popularized
to say we got to get more income so that
we get out of debt faster save and
invest at a much greater rate that's
something you're interested in yes or
no yeah all right what do you do
now for work um uh I am an automotive
detailer oh okay automotive detailer
you're making how much an
hour um I currently make 1750 uh plus
tips okay and what's your long-term
ideas I'll bet you've got two or three
or maybe four ideas of what you would
like to do because I know you don't want
to stay in auto detailing is that
true uh yeah I I really I really like
the job uh but it's kind of of iffy uh
in the summertime and fall and spring
people you know were pretty booked up so
pretty much a point what would you like
to do five I mean if you could try
something totally new next week and you
didn't have to commit to it for the next
30 years of your life and you knew you
weren't going to screw up meaning you
were going to do fine you were going to
enjoy it what would you
try um probably something in the
woodworking or welding industry um
very interesting I love that and you
know what's interesting it that there's
a tie into to the fact that you enjoy
detailing cars the the the operating
word here for you ban Brian for a long
term for you is you're about details and
when you're working with your hands and
your eyes to get into details to make
something look aesthetically pleasing so
that could be the woodworking or uh
welding something that's fixing
something or designing something that's
really appealing to you
yes yeah that's great so here's the deal
I want to see you making steps I want
you doing exactly what Jade told you to
do okay but right now we're looking to
pick up maybe a second or a third job I
don't think you have to have three jobs
but I would tell you a $20 to $22 an
hour job is around Superior Wisconsin
and it's not going to require a college
degree and that's going to change our
situation really quick but that's short
long term I want you going all right
what does it look like for me to move
into woodworking or welding so I'm going
to give you my book called The Proximity
principle and here's what it says in
order to do what bana wants to do she's
got to be around people that are doing
it and in places where it's happening so
in the next 30 days I'm going to
challenge you all right I'm going to
give you the book and it'll it'll
inspire you to do it and tell you what
to do but it's just a simple as you
getting around somebody that's in
woodworking somebody that's in welding
hey how'd you get into it what are the
qualifications do I need to go to a
trade school the answer is yes for
welding uh I'm not sure about
woodworking but if you got some natural
Talent you start doing some side
projects helping out a wood worker maybe
being a you know an assistant where you
get paid now I've got more money to pay
off my debt to get my emergency fund
fully funded but I'm learning the trade
of woodworking or I'm going to take a
welding school after I get out of debt
and after I get uh the emergency fund
fully funded and I'm going to pay my way
through welding school and I'm going to
come out and I'm probably going to be
starting in the 55 to $5,000 range with
a path to six figures and maybe owning
your own welding business Brianna now I
just talked a lot what are you feeling
what are you
thinking um it's I mean it's 100%
possible I just need someone to you know
kind of give me a little shove in the
right direction I'm shoving you I'm
shoving you if I shove you anymore I'm
not a gentleman yeah I was about to say
we going to have to call the cops that's
right well I got my friend here she's
going to keep me in check what I I'm
saying is I absolutely believe that that
path is possible for you I'm going to
give you the book which will stay with
you as some accountability okay but what
I'm saying is you need to decide which
one of those paths and the way you
decide is by hanging out with people
that are doing you find out the good the
bad the ugly and your head and heart get
together and you go ding ding ding or
like from Family Feud and once you
figure out which direction you want to
go you go all right what does it take to
get qualified I got an answer I got a
Target and I'm going to walk the baby
steps right into that next future for me
that that that future where I could be a
sixf figure earner a multi-millionaire
because you're going to invest in baby
St for so that's good Ken it's doable
hang on the line we'll give you the book
The Proximity principle uh close us out
with a little ra there to Brian you know
I just want to let her know whenever I
have a boyfriend girlfriend living
together I you know she's paying $600
but truly it's 1,200 I want to make sure
she gets to the point that she can
handle that rent on her own because I
never want somebody to feel like like oh
we were sharing this place together and
I can't go anywhere because I can't
afford it so get that income up girl and
I'm old school come on ladies make that
guy put a ring on okay this is the Ramy
[Music]
[Applause]
show hey guys I've told you before about
Christian Healthcare Ministries a cost
sharing Ministry but listen to Jenna a
chm member she says one of my biggest
concerns about entrepreneurship and
motherhood was figuring out how to take
care of our health expenses but we have
found a solution that works for us in an
incredible way she loves that with chm
she can help other families who need it
and receive help back when her own
family has an eligible medical event chm
has been a godsend for Jenna that's her
chm story and it could be yours learn
more and join at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Jade warshaw joins me Triple
8825 5225 is the phone number 8825 5225
let's go to Dayton of Florida and Daniel
is there Daniel how can we
help yeah how you doing good how are you
sir I'm all right Great's um I have a
question I'm uh trying to make a
decision I'm I'm 45 years old my wife is
36 um we recently got married this past
November we've been together almost 5
years MH um we are about
$128,000 in debt between like personal
uh debt and then debt from our
businesses um she's in she's a nurse she
had a uh a uh nursing supply store that
she had went business before okay and
that failed so we have debt from that um
I'm a barber and I have the CDL so I've
been the past say two three years I've
been jumping in out of Barbering and
trucking trying to you know decide which
um field I I want to stay in okay and
I'm in the same situation like I'm right
now with the debt I'm scared I'm a
little nervous and I'm about to jump
back into Trucking and I really don't
want to but that is like steady income
for meate about the barbering how yeah
how much more how much more does do the
trucking allow you to make than if you
were to stay in the
barbering all right right now I I go off
the numbers right last year in barbering
um I made maybe about
26,000 and then if I go into Trucking
and um I stay in it for a full year I I
have P to make anywhere from 65 to 80
depending on how hard I run okay but but
the tradeoff is that you know I'm in the
truck weeks at a time away from home
right but I'm jumping in as we go okay
cuz we're covering some this is a work
question but we got some debt we need to
take care of so um if I'm you I'm going
to jump in the truck because it's the
quickest route for me to juice my income
and we're talking about maybe as much is
almost four times the income and you
don't have to be in that truck forever
but it is but is absolutely the
possibility I don't think you have to
leave uh barbering forever maybe maybe
you won't have much time to do it on the
week weekends when you're not in the
truck if you do I'd be cutting hair as
that second gig but if you don't let's
go all in on the trucking to get that
income up so we can start to clean up
this
$128,000 mess now you mentioned your
wife is in nursing or was did nursy
school is she a nurse right now yes she
is what's her
income um don't know off the uh top of
my head but I can tell you what she uh
her two we her last paycheck for two
weeks was deposited was
2500 okay so around 5,000 a month okay
yes and um you don't know this because
I'm guessing you guys aren't on a budget
or am I wrong no you're right you're
correct all right so
um uh I'm going to bring Jade in here
and let's walk through these numbers
because we we got to pay the 128 off but
um do you understand what I'm saying are
you with me on the trucking thing that's
not a long-term play but that's your
best short-term play yeah and I just see
that somebody to confirm that cuz I was
feeling you know uh conflicted about it
but you know hearing you say that it it
yeah reassures me and I get it you love
being a barber
right yes but listen this time in the
truck is going to allow you to figure
out what is it that I'm going to have to
do differently next time around to make
more than $26,000 because you're worth
way more than
$26,000 and so we got to figure out how
to do that better next time around and
um it might be after we get this debt
paid off it might be staying in the
truck a little bit longer to figure out
how do I turn that business into more
money but Jade I know you wanted to jump
because here's what I'm thinking I'm
thinking we have an opportunity to test
two concepts right now K I agree number
one if you for the for the year just
started right we're still pretty fresh
and new in this new year if you do the
driver thing and you hit somewhere in
the middle and you make $70,000 a year
and your wife's a nurse she's making
60,000 a year so you're at 130 yeah
if you live like you're only making 26k
on that barber money and you use
everything else to start paying off this
debt and you're out of debt in the next
two and a half years or I'm sorry in the
next one and a half years you'll you'll
know then that when you're done paying
off this debt okay I can if we wanted to
take the financial hit and me strike out
as a barber I know I have this Baseline
of customers and I can just build from
there at least you'll know financially
you can do it because you've been doing
it for the last year and a half toay off
debt so there's part of me that's like
hey that's really great then the other
part of me I'm I'm just wondering I'm
not passing a judgment but I feel like
60k is low for a nurse right now am I
wrong am I right does it depend on the
area uh definitely depends on the area
right now we're not actually in Daytona
they we just said that because they ask
for the closest major city it also
depends on the type of nursing what is
she doing and where is she doing it she
is um she is is a traveling nurse like
she goes to the she stays local but she
goes to the her uh patients homes and
like she uh geriatric she
just okay so that's and again I'm not a
C I'm not an expert on this part but I
think the geriatric nursing nursing and
kind of that local thing is is somewhat
limiting she has definite room to grow
in her income but the point here is what
I think can happen where in especially
in your area I think you can live off of
your income 70 and I think you guys can
put 60,000 on this debt every year and I
think you're out of debt in two year in
a year and a half two years I agree
Daniel how does that hit
you there's one more element to the to
to the puzzle is it your wife working
extra overtime
hours no it's not no we we just found
out oh yeah we just found out that she
is 8 weeks pregnant so we're expecting
another child we already have a
four-year old okay okay so even more
fuel under the fire now here's here's
here's where this turns this in a
frustrating Direction possibly for you I
want you for until your wife has this
baby I want you to pause these efforts
because I want to make sure you stack up
as much money as possible now here's the
thing and I feel like I have to be very
very clear on this you're pausing you
haven't even started a dead snowball yet
but we were going to we if you hadn't
told me about the baby I would have said
okay you're doing your dead snowball
you're living on you know the 70,000
you're throwing 60,000 a year at this
thing um MH because you what I want to
clarify here and be really just hear me
so clearly so many times people call in
they've already started their debt
snowball and they just want to know
where to go next but they're having a
baby so we tell them to pause the debt
snowball in order to stack up money we
call it stor mode stack up money until
the baby comes make sure you can pay you
know for all the costs associated with
the baby then when the baby's home and
healthy you guys take whatever money is
left throw it on the debt and keep the
debt snowball going in your situation
Daniel you're going to have to be doubly
diligent because you haven't even really
gotten started yet you haven't even
really gotten on a budget yet and it
could be very easy for you to just kind
of lull back into your old ways coming
off of this call because you're like
well I guess I can't start the baby
steps yet I can't really do anything so
until this Baby's Gone So I it don't do
that
okay don't do it I want you to stack up
money as though you were going to put it
on the debt with equal intensity how
much what do you think the number is for
him I think they live off of his income
no no I know but how much is he saving
for stor mode what do you think that
number is I think he's not I don't think
he's touching his debt
snowball I understand but what's he
saving per month based on this you're
saying everything outside of their bills
basically whatever he would have put on
the debt snowball whatever you would
have put on the that snowball you're
saving it put it in a high yield savings
account and you know everything goes
well you know we're praying baby goes
well Mama goes well everything is good
and all you're on the hook for is your
deductible which is probably $5 or
$7,000 whatever it is and then all that
extra money that you've been saving up
over the course of these months when
everybody comes home safely you're
throwing it at the debt and it better be
a lot yeah now that's 130,000 if you get
in the truck so and she's got to work
too and here's the thing um you have got
to get in the budget you've got to
budget save those are the two things
that Jade told you to do budget so that
you can save and then you take on the
debt snowball but I'm going to tell you
one other thing brother you've got to
commit no more debt on businesses no
more borrowing you guys you took in way
too much debt now you can get out of
this but you're going to be gutting it
out for a couple of years that means
you're in the truck yeah and when you're
not in the truck you're clipping some
hair mhm and that's just how it goes
until you get out of this and you can do
it my friend appreciate the call this is
the r
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Jade warshaw joins me the phone
number if you want to join us here on
the conversation Isle
8825 5225 all right now for our
neighborly question of the day it is
neighborly your hub for Home Services
winner is is rougher in some areas of
the country than others but there are
things that make sense to do no matter
where you live that's why neighborly has
a helpful winter checklist you can
download for free you can check it out
at neighborly
decom Ramsey all righty today's question
comes from Jillian in Delaware how do I
deal with incompetent workers Ken
they're always making excuses or blaming
someone else for not doing their job the
work that I do depends on them getting
things turned in on time and I have to
chase them down every day the boss
doesn't seem to see what's going on what
can I do oh boy okay uh this is a tough
one in that um their lack of diligence
is affecting your ability to do your job
so you have one way to take this and
that's up um you said the boss doesn't
seem to see what's going on if you were
on the phone I could get a little bit
more detail so I'm flying a bit blind
but I would be going to the boss going
hey I I'm not playing tattletail I'm not
griping I'm just telling you what I'm
experiencing and I need you to weigh in
and so then you describe so I'm supposed
to do this
ABC but I can't do ABC if this over here
isn't being done and I need your help
because it's affecting my ability to get
the job done can you check into this or
is there something that what can I do
that's the way you got to take this to
them and you're going to find out very
quickly whether or not this leader gives
a crap that's what I'm wondering and and
we're going to find out if in fact
um your co-workers lack of diligence
really does affect you as much as you
think I got a
hunch and Jade this is why I love the
question of the day but it's so limiting
because I can't dig yeah but I just
wonder if this person here Jillian who
seems to be very diligent I'd hire
Jillian just I would and just tell
because Jillian's GNA get her job done
okay I think Jillian could be focused a
little too much on what everyone else is
doing cuz it's not up to her standard
and it's irritating more than it is
limiting her I could be wrong well if
her job depends on if it's kind of like
a a flow right then it is limiting and
and they're laate on their deadlines it
may not be it can cause her to be late
on her deadlines that I'm acknowledging
like if I don't turn in my articles on
time I get it I'm throwing else it might
be a situation where it's more
irritating than limiting and in that
case here's why I'm bringing this up cuz
I a lot of people who can identify with
this in that case you got to do your job
and you do your job really really well
and it is going to then shine a light on
everything else and if that doesn't fix
the
situation we're moving on so let let's
roll play Let's R play this out let's
roll play this out cuz you be the good
you be the leader I'mma Be Jillian you
be Jillian you know I just wanted to
bring this to you I'm not trying to be a
tattletail I'm not trying to you know
tell on anybody but I found it difficult
to hit my deadlines and here's what I'm
finding is the challenge
um Michael you know I love Michael he's
great on the team but he's consistently
late in turning in his projects and it's
causing me to be late or have to work
harder to hit my deadlines and I just I
wonder if there's something I can do to
kind of make things run smoother or if
this is something you've noticed have
you talked to Michael about it I haven't
I you know I wanted to bring it up
because I didn't want to okay you know
do you feel like you talk to him about
it he might be defensive and it might
not go so well is there a little bit of
just kind of some emotional safety we
want to you know i' I've emailed him
sometimes and said hey I just want to
check in I'm I'm waiting for you to get
this so I can start all right I need you
to detail for me what specifically he
isn't doing and how that's affecting
your ability can you lay that out for me
well yeah because I if he doesn't turn
in his articles in time I'm late right
and if I'm late then I'm looking bad and
unless I point back to him it all falls
on me so I don't always want to be
saying well it was because of Michael it
was because of Michael got it and do you
have can you give me three specific
examples yes Monday Tuesday and
Wednesday and so that's a good leader by
the way I'm role playing the good leader
that's a great leader and then the
leader's going to go all right let me
talk to Michael let me dig into it and
I'm going to get back to you and I'm
sorry that you're dealing with this
frustration that process is on me so I
need to figure out a solution stay tun
that's what I want to hear that's that's
that's the good leader but again you
know we're role playing and so if that's
the response great wait if it's not the
response start looking handle your
business so that you can hope F be able
to control the perception of you if you
leave you don't want to become a thorn
in that Leader's side because that
person if it's an unhealthy leader they
can end up hurting you as you go to look
for something else so in that situation
you go I can't fix it I tried let me
stay above The Fray protect my image my
personal brand at all cost that would be
the backside of it if it doesn't help
and a lot of times leaders aren't going
to fix it and that sucks let's go to
belon in Richmond Virginia Belton how
can we help
yes um so um thank you st my call um so
I'm 32 single no kids um graduating
distal my PhD and I need a new car um so
my question is should I be more um I'm
sorry the only debt that I have is my
student loans is about 67k how'd you
forget about
[Laughter]
that keep going um and um so I'm trying
to figure out if I should be more modest
with the
and um do something under 20K about
100,000 miles or put a little bit more
money into getting a newer car that will
last longer how much money do you have I
have about 10K saved and I plan on my
goal is to save at least another 10 to
15K this year I make 80 grand a
year okay um let me give you a couple
I'm just going to give you a couple
rules of thumb and then I want to see
how it Jes with you so our rule of thumb
THB is we don't buy brand new cars until
we've have a millionaire net worth a 1
million net worth and the reason for
that is because new cars brand new cars
lose 60 to 70% of their value in the
first 3 to four years really quickly and
most of us can't afford to take that hit
like we we need that money like we want
that money so that's that's the rule of
thumb there that's rule of thumb number
one second rule of thumb is we say okay
if you say I'm going to buy a nice used
car we would say that it shouldn't be
worth more than half of your yearly
income so in your case it's just you
you're single if you make 80,000 40,000
would be your maximum limit so that's
number one on a used car thing three is
we suggest that you would pay off your
debt especially if you have a car that
works and runs that you would pay off
your debt first before you even consider
buying a another car or a new car or
used car and then finally the kicker is
this is thing four we would suggest that
you pay cash for whatever you do get so
you've got four guidelines there um I
think the first one we can tick off the
box like I think we can both agree that
you buying a brand new car right now is
probably not a good idea yeah so we can
take that one off the list then and that
which means we can agree and I think we
can both agree on the idea that 40%
would be or 40,000 would be the max
right that's half of your income so
that's a little bit more than what I was
thinking exactly so we're in agreeance
on that next thing is can we agree that
whatever you get you you pay cash for
it okay I'm hitting the resistance I
like it I like it Belton okay so let's
start with that let's agree that you pay
cash because here's the thing there's
two thoughts to this because I I you're
GNA go off of here and do what you want
to do but the last thing you know what
it feels like to have $67,000 of debt
the last thing you need to do is go back
into debt or add any debt to that
correct right yeah so let's solve the
problem the problem in your financial
life right now is debt and I always say
you because you're making a good income
you're getting the PHD you're doing all
the things right but the the glaring
obvious problem here is that $67,000 of
student loan debt that's standing out I
always tell people you can't solve a
problem while simultaneously creating it
so if you want to solve this problem of
debt belon you've got to decide I don't
borrow money anymore I'm not going into
debt anymore and that includes the car
you said you've got 10,000 saved and you
can maybe save another 10 or 15 more
that's
$25,000 where I come from that's that's
a decent bag like that's a nice car yeah
belt I'm going to jump in real quick
what what do you what what do you what
do you hedging on when she throws that
at you and you're going I don't know
what's holding you up from going I'm all
in I I I guess the the I guess growing
up is about being that cash pour thing
of like not having like like having cash
in the bank versus like putting it but
it's not yours it's not yours as long as
you owe
$67,000 you don't have any money you
still owe 55 57,000 you see what I'm
saying that's just basic math so what I
would suggest you do keep a $1,000 saved
pay off that 67,000 as quickly as
possible save up cash and pay cash for a
car this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
oh
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the Ramsey Show it's
where we help you win in your life win
with your money win in your work and win
in your relationships Triple 8 825 5225
8825 5225 is the number we'd love to
take your question today we Bean me kin
Coleman and she Jade warshaw we are here
for you this hour you ready to go
partner I'm ready we never told him the
special surprise Ken well I kind of felt
like you gave me the vibe like you
didn't you didn't want to reveal that
cuz it's a very personal kind of a thing
so I didn't know if you were picking up
what I was laying down turning 30 is a
big deal okay saying turning 30 years of
age uh it's if you're a big fan of Jade
especially for the second time and you
should be uh tomorrow is Jade's birthday
and so I'm not going to be on with you
tomorrow so I wanted to say happy
birthday to you we're so glad you're
here she's taking Ramy solutions by
storm and um just Stacy and I love her
and Sam and they two beautiful kiddos
and and they've just become a part of
our community right away and so we're
celebrating you tonight thanks some of
us that's all I'm going to say we're
going to keep the details on the
download on the D but uh Happy Birthday
early birthday thank you Ken Coleman so
all of you folks jump on the Instagram
and wish her a happy birthday would you
show her how much you love her and I
know she would appreciate that so not
going to tell you how old she is
although I actually know 30 Ken okay
that's what we're going with plus 10
okay Ellie is up in Lexington Kentucky
Ellie how can we
help hi um this will probably be a
pretty quick question uh my husband and
I started back in November on The Total
Money Makeover and we've been able to
pay off a lot of debt so thank you guys
awesome so uh we will have all of our
debt paid off by October and we'll be
able to save up a fully funded emergency
fund by June for six months nice so
after that um we've already paused
investing so we could have our home paid
off in two and a half to three years if
we kept up the gazelle intensity uh but
we wouldn't be investing the 15% at that
time would it be wise to only invest up
to our company's match since it's going
to be such a short time frame or should
we jump in on the 15% right away i' in
your case I'd walk it in anybody's case
i' walk it through as as the steps say
um I know and it's hard cuz you can get
excited it's like listen if we just keep
going with this intensity we can have
the house paid off but there's a reason
you
know there's a fine line because
obviously people call in all the time
who are further along age-wise than you
and you know we're we'll tell them to
pause investing to pay off their debt
but then when it comes over to you I'm
like no don't pause you know you know
don't pause investing do your investing
and then pay off your house later the
part of the the reason for that is if it
makes sense for you to take advantage of
time in the compound interest equation
we want you to take advantage of time if
it makes sense um and in your case it
does make sense because you've already
paid off your debt you like you said
you'll have your 3 to six months saved
up you've done everything right there's
no reason for you to continue to put
this off and um lose out on any time
gaining compound interest because the
fact is you are still going to pay off
your home home and you're still going to
be gaining equity and value in your home
during that time so really nothing is
lost um for you there's a higher gain
and there's a higher percentage of you
earning more money if you go ahead and
start investing now take advantage of
that compound interest and like you said
in in a few short years your home will
still be paid off here's the thing you
might start making more money you might
have some other things that work in your
favor that keep that timeline very
similar without you even realizing it I
agree Ellie you're going to look back
and go I'm so glad I listened to Jade
and got that that three extra years or
the two extra years of investing and
getting that started cuz you guys are
going to crush this there's a reason why
years ago Dave put those steps in order
and it is about one word Ellie and
that's
momentum and that leads to M money you
hear meum M money moment equals m money
Ken you're a true G Ellie are you with
me yeah awesome thank you guys and happy
birthday Jade thank you happy birthday
AJ I don't want to miss the fact that
you just called me a did you call me a
real G you're a real G you I don't even
know what that means momentum M money
come on K you've been sitting next to me
too long I grew up in the '90s that's
all it is know who wears a white
turtleneck it's not okay first of all
it's not a turtleneck it's a mock neck
thank you thank you it is it is a and
it's and it's actually a roll neck is
the traditional usage of this you go to
jcrew.com uh this is a roll neck sweater
not a mock not a a turtleneck come on
get it right I got to fix it all right
we can keep going dele as in release is
that right Detroit Michigan the Motor
City yes sir Happy Birthday Jay oh thank
you Delise I mean I'm making your day I
feel like a new woman this is great all
right dele Release Me From all this
please help me out what's your question
okay my my question is should I sell my
van or move into it
wait a second what are you serious about
moving into this van what kind of van is
it it better be a great van it's a Class
B um I so I'm 60 and I'll be retiring in
five to seven years I'm selling my home
and I'm uh uh paying down off off my car
and my credit card and it'll either be
part of my van but I'm upside down in
the van okay let's let's look at this it
okay let's look at this cuz I want to
get on I want to see if I can get on the
same page as you and and I might end up
seeing it from a new Viewpoint which I
think I might um okay yeah do you mind
if we start with the house how much you
plan on making on the
house uh I owe 170 and they say I'm it's
uh selling for 400 okay and after you
sell have you kind of done the math what
do you think you'll walk away
with um
190 uh maybe
maybe okay that was a good question I
wasn't ready for that
one the van I was 107 on the van 14 on
the car and 11 on the card okay 14k 11k
and I'm sorry go back and tell me the
van amount 111 uh yeah 10 108 108
basically okay so I put me put me in the
note tell me what a Class B van is what
does that
mean um that is the the higher cost Vans
oh they're just Vans with with a camper
with camper camper bed and everything
yeah okay and it's going down in value
because you said you're upside down I'm
upside down it'll probably if it sells
for 90 that'd be great but that means
I'd owe you know 20,000 on it okay um if
it sells for 90 that'd be great okay do
you have any money
saved no no money Saed trying to get
together for the for the uh retirement
my saving situation was basically with
the house I put 100,000 uh in when I
bought it okay what's the car worth that
you owe 14
on um it's a 2019 it might be worth 20
sell uh something like 17 18 I'm sorry
you need to sell that today yeah I'd
sell the car and I'd take that money and
buy yourself a cash beater um we're
going to hold you over cuz I want to
keep helping you with this yeah we got
some work to do but my goodness okay you
can get out of this but I don't think I
don't know Delise I don't think you're
going to end up in a van down by the
river okay that's our goal but you got
to hang with this Luxy it's luxury I bet
it is but still it's a van oh my
goodness that's all right Jade is on it
she's got her notes over there she's
warming up she's going to stretch during
the break you take a stretch as well
we're going to be right back we're going
to help delease out and release her from
living in the van this is the ramsy
show
[Music]
[Applause]
all right welcome back to the Ramy show
I'm Ken Coleman Jade warshaw Jade
warshaw is with me and I boy said that a
little too quick that's all right and uh
we're taking your calls 8825 5225 we
took a call right before the break delis
is with us in Detroit I want to set the
call up if you're just kind of hanging
in here or jumping in with us uh the
question she had was should I sell my
van and she's got a really nice van I'm
talking it's like a camper it's Deluxe
but she owes a lot of money on it about
$108,000 so the question is should she
sell uh her house and move into the van
and she's got some equity in the house
so that's where we left it Jade pick us
back up we're walking through kind of
her debt um we haven't gotten into
income yet so take it away and we'll and
I'll jump in as well okay so deliss uh
we figured out we should probably sell
this car it's you owe 14,000 but you
might be able to get 20,000 for it so
that gives you a spread that's a $6,000
spread am I
right yes perfect so that gives you some
money that you could buy a car in cash
no more payments and you're good to go
on that um then you've got this credit
card are you working at all
still yes I I make
160 okay Delise that's just what we're
going to need uh to to release us from
the sorry Ken I had to take your I know
I'm sorry it's the greatest name it is
absolutely the best name of any caller
I've ever taken I'm not even kidding
it's fantastic I'm obsessed so here's
what I love are you single it's just you
yes okay yes you've got a great income
you're going to pay off this $11,000
credit card like fast fast in a month in
a month and a half like this thing is
gone right because you make 160,000 what
do you take home every
month uh
78 $78,000 $78,000 okay and you're
paying your morgage morage you've got
this class B van you should be able to
pay off that credit card in the next two
months fair
enough okay now hold on a second I'm
detecting something here I could be
wrong I hear you hear her it's cuz she's
not on a budget 100% And I don't think
she knows that she can do that am I
right Delise that's right so I want so
listen my colleague she she's a force of
nature I sniff it out but I'm going to
jump in here and we got to slow this
down and help you walk through what it's
going to take and she's right it's a
budget yeah do you have any idea
month-to month are you are you just
seeing yourself make it at paycheck to
paycheck right now basically yeah okay
so right now you don't see the margin so
you can't believe that you can pay off
that debt as quickly as Jade's telling
you so I think we need to Camp here for
a minute budgeting like what are your
what are your biggest
expenses the van is 783 a month yeah
there's one the house is the house is uh
the house is uh 1,600 a month gets us
downsizing that's about 2400 there
where's the rest of the money going what
do you think the big expenditures are I
know you've not done a budget uh the car
the car is 300 I'm pay I'm gonna I was
GNA pay that off with the uh house
selling and then the car we're not we're
not selling the house okay so you're at
27 listen it's a budget cuz I we're
adding up these numbers and you're at
half of your in I mean you're at half of
your income so that money is going
somewhere and it's going to your
lifestyle it's going to the things that
you like to do with your friends and
your family I mean it happens to the
best of us you guys L it to you guys is
going to eating and so I I'm started to
cut out that whole dinner thing okay
when you get off the phone today you're
going to leave with every dollar and I
want you to have the premium version um
at least we'll give you a trial version
so you can see how it works you that is
the foundation for all of this if you
don't get this Budget on and popping and
you can set it up in 5 minutes it's
super easy and if you ever feel like you
get hung up there's every dollar YouTube
channel that you can check out and it'll
answer all your questions or you know
slide into my DMs I'll answer your
questions but um it's very easy very
intuitive that is your homework for
tonight you get off this call you
download every dollar and you start
setting up your budget tonight and we do
um every dollar okay every dollar and we
do delease what's called a zerob based
budget which means that when you open up
every dollar you'll you'll plug in what
you get paid and how often you get paid
and it'll show it at the top of the
screen in green like okay Delise you got
78 you know $7,800 to spend and then you
literally quote unquote spend the money
before the month begins so you go
through on your budget and say okay I'm
going to put 783 for the car and I'm
going to put 1,600 for the mortgage and
I'm going to put 300 for my car and you
go through and it'll subtract it from
your income so you'll start to see what
money you have to spend on bills and
what you have left and what you have
left is what we call margin and that
margin is what you're going to use to
pay off this credit card and I here's
what I know Delise when you sit down and
do that budget tonight you will be
shocked and amazed how much margin you
had because there's certain things that
you're going to guess on right you're
going to say okay out to eat I don't
know what I spent maybe I spent 400
maybe I spent and you're going to pull
up that old you know bank statement
whatever your bank is Chase Bank of
America hopefully not you're going to
pull up your bank statement and you're
going to look for the past month and
you're going to look at all the
transactions that were out to and you're
going to add them up and you're going to
go oh my goodness so I got to I got to
ask Delise why the van why' you buy the
van and I'm not asking this for you to
defend it no no it's a great question uh
my mom died and uh we had just gotten
into Co my grandchildren and my daughter
were living with me and so I had to get
away so you just bought the van to say I
got to drive and and get out on the open
road and heal and yeah and I did 48
states so I mean you know yeah okay so
so Jade's walked through the budget
thing but the reason I asked that
question is is is the way you presented
your question at the first
was should I move into my
van did I hear that right yeah yeah wait
a second you got this house living in
these van I know but you've got this
amazing house which becomes a tremendous
investment you've got a good amount of
equity in this home and to me I'd be
getting rid of the van and hold on to
the house
think about it Delise with what we just
laid out in two months cuz I think that
you have probably a margin of $4,500
every month in two months you're going
to pay off the credit
card two and a half months and in
another two and a half months you're
going to save up $10,000 and you're
going to put that
$10,000 with the class B van and just
set it aside and then you're going to
save up another $10,000 and put it with
the class B B and then you're going to
sell it because you won't be upside down
anymore and then you're going to have
your entire income to put towards paying
off your house when the time
comes okay so you're going to you're
going to now let kin said have an asset
that's yours it's your house it already
has Equity now you're debt free you got
a paid for car in cash and this is going
to happen in the course of less than six
months and then here's the other thing
Del you were talking about retirement
you're doing what Jade's talking about
Jade's got you on a path to an emergency
fund of 3 to 6 months of your expenses
within how long what are you mapping try
to she's going to be at of debt in 5
months and then you're going to save up
6 months of expenses yeah so and that's
basic expenses which you will be able to
look at your budget and see okay what do
I need to just kind of keep things
running like what's what's my basic
expenses so you'll save up six months of
that that's going to take you another
six months so by the time you're 61
you're going to be completely debt free
cash car 6 months of expenses now you're
61 and you get to decide am I going to
keep working or not if you decide hey
you know I've got some more years left
in me I'm going to work till I'm 65
Social Security starts at 62 yeah I want
you to start taking those six those uh
distributions from from Social Security
and I want you to start investing them
do with 15% of your
income very little retirement supposedly
uh 60,000 tot all right so the point is
here is in about a year with the kind of
income you're making you're going to
start pouring on top of that 60,000 You'
be surprised at how quickly that'll
compound and if you can delay retir
until 70 then you're going to get a lot
more of Social Security and that gives
yourself almost 9 years to be piling up
cash at this point you probably have the
house paid off let's say that house now
grows to 450,000 in value 500,000 in
value uh I think you can make the case
it by the time you're 7075 you're going
to be in really really good shape and
let me but it starts now the next 6
months the next year yeah let me roll
that out further for you cuz said it
once you get that 6 months saved up
you're you're investing 15% of your
income every single month every single
month you're making extra payments on
the mortgage every single month because
you've got the margin to do that when
you get 62 you're still working take
that social security for the next 6 or
seven years invest it this is how you do
it and you're going to be just fine give
yourself another 10 years to lease this
thing looks totally different yes and
you're not living in a van Riv by the
river or by the campground
you get rid of it that's an appreciating
asset get rid of the van as quick as
possible thanks for the call deise we
love you you're such a fun character
this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
all right welcome back to the Ramsey
Show I'm Ken Coleman Jade warshaw joins
me this hour8 825 5225 is the number you
know every once in a while Jade it's
really fun because we do have a live
studio audience and I should take this
moment to just say if you ever want to
join us uh go to the website ramsy
solutions.com uh they've got a show
calendar on there and uh we'd love to
know that you're coming but we give
people uh you know free coffee and teas
and there's baked goods over there and
we just love for folks to come watch the
show well Melissa uh joined us today in
the lobby and she's from Indianapolis
I'm told and so every once in a while
we'll take a question from the from the
audience in the lobby and so Melissa is
standing over there on the debt-free
stage hello Melissa hi Jade hi hi Ken
how are you I'm good thank you all right
so I'm told you have a question for for
us so take it away what's going on all
right um I'm a physician and I'm board
certified in Family Medicine okay but
I'm about to change Specialties um I um
was accepted into a fellowship for
hospice and paliative Medicine okay and
it's a 12-month training program it
starts July 1st all right and um I'm a
single mom with five kids and so yeah
how old are the kids uh they're 16 14 12
11 and six bless heart so they're a lot
of fun oh man okay so you're busy I am I
am um but I after the fellowship
obviously it would it would be good to
relatively quickly uh get another job of
some sort um and uh so I need to figure
out what I want to do and the fellowship
program and the hospital system that
it's associated with they offer um
something called an early incentive
program okay basically they would trade
an extra stipend per month during the
fellowship um for my commitment to do um
whatever position in their company
beyond the training program and so if I
were to take the stien for say six
months of the fellowship um program I'd
be committing to six months in that
position how much stien going to be uh
it's like 22500 a month extra can you
live off of that so I get paid also um
for the fellowship itself it's sort of
like a Residency program right so
that'll be somewhere between 60 and
80,000 oh um and for the 12 months and
then I also I'm a health officer so I I
help um lead a great team in a health
department in a small town and um so I
make like 23,000 from that as well so
where's the problem um so I was just
curious if I should go ahead and sign
and um commit to doing some position
with them beyond the fellowship okay so
all right or cuz I don't have to that's
an optional thing or
I go on my own and over the next you
know 16 months or so umy look for
whatever position that I want of my own
okay so I love the question let me ask
it back to you okay okay and I love it
by the way you're doing great you're
doing great
um would you rather go out on your own
or would you rather forget the stip and
the Sten is a non-factor I appreciate
you share I don't actually need that you
don't need the money that you're fine uh
the question is would you rather kind of
step into their existing job in that
program and kind of learn the the the
ropes and kind of get into it and get
your sea legs or would you rather say if
I had the opportunity just as I have the
this the job at the hospital if I had my
own opportunity or something else which
would I rather have where where's your
gut at yeah I'd probably rather do my
own thing just because I have more
control and flexibility and all of that
then that's the answer I I'm trying to
simplify it there's now I want you to
push back here but based on what you
shared with us so far the pros of it
obviously you know the stien but um you
know some sort of guaranteed position I
guess so that there's less um unknown
all right so let's play this out all
right if you uh went out on your own and
you get done with the fellowship you're
going to make 60 to 80 on that you're
making 23 you're already a doctor do you
have any debt at all what kind of funny
shape are you in baby step seven you're
on baby step seven yeah all right walk
us through baby step seven what is your
baby step seven look like what kind of
retirement do you have um so I'm
actually I'm going through a divorce
right now so it'll be about half of what
it is now um and you know by the time
the fellowship starts most likely but um
right now right now it's like 500,000 so
it'll be you know maybe actually for my
part I'll have the paid off house and
like a 100 to 200,000 I I don't see any
problems with this so I was looking at
you on M I think financially I I I feel
like I'm doing pretty well CU you're
still going to keep 23 uh with this
community health thing yes I'll continue
to do that yep yeah I'd bet on me the is
not worth it no not to lock yourself
into six more months you said double the
stipend so it would give you 4500 if I'm
if I was paying attention no it just
it's 2,000 or 2500 extra per month and I
think I don't know the whatever the 60
to 880,000 ends up being exactly you
know divide over 12 months that's how
much I'll make per month during the
but I mean obviously I make more right
now I work only parttime but I'm a
hospitalist so I take care of patients
that are admitted the hospital and you
know I make $200,000 with bonuses and
everything plus the 23,000 so way to go
come on girl a single that's what I'm
talking about what are what are your
fears on this cuz I I sense that there
that it's something there still I think
the losing uh the flexibility because I
want to see these five kids grow up I
want to be there to you know raise them
which is why I'm part time right now and
so I I need that flexibility I don't
want to I guess I don't want to give
that up and lock myself into anything
more you know this 12 months is already
um okay let's stop you don't need to she
doesn't need to you don't let me yeah I
I think we need to pause right here cuz
now this is this is what I'm getting at
because I could still sense and feel
that okay this is not a money question
this is a time question so that would
still be there this path is still going
to be there once the six-year-old is a
certain level the I mean I'm going
through the teen thing right now your
oldest is how old 16 and a half yeah I
mean my oldest is about ready to
graduate high school and I can't even
talk about it so I yeah she and I will
finish our our programs now the same
basically the same time in going to look
like if you take the path that you're
working for yourself TimeWise you're not
going to have the time that you have now
yes no I I would hope that beyond the
fellowship beyond the training program
so this will be um um July of 2025 that
I could find something I could go
part-time in the new specialty or I
could or I could do full-time but I
could make it my own and just tell them
here's the schedule I need okay so now
Jade that's a slam dunk for me and
that's why you would never go work for
the hospital the hospital's not going to
give you that kind of Freedom yeah um I
don't know I don't know I guess there's
a lot of unknowns and I may end up doing
something within this company because I
do have some Suburban rural areas which
are closer to home um just you know if
it happens to work out then great I
don't like I said I don't necessarily
need the dipen and have the the absolute
definite that's what I'm going to do
because I really want to take when the
fellowship's done I want to take kind of
a month off you know I want to and then
in August that year I want to move my
daughter into college and things like
that and I don't want to be I guess I
just don't want to be stuck this
direction of medicine is what's really
on your heart yes so then I'm going tell
you something go do it I think this is
about Mama time and so whatever step you
take take going down this path must be
run through the filter of how much
flexibility I have for this short season
cuz the kiddos are going to get old fast
so I think it's the mama time is what is
Becomes Her new def filter what what do
you think I just when you talked about
receiving a stip in in exchange for 6
months in a role that you don't really
know what it's going to be they could
put you anywhere I just I don't see the
benefit not with you not with the money
that you're already
making and that you'll make coming out I
just I can't see where that
you're a working mom kind of what I was
thinking I mean you you get this issue
you're a working mom and then once you
come out and you you do strike out on
your
own I didn't write it down but there's
the other job that you have that you're
making 23,000 off of that's eating up
time you can let that go
mhm yeah well I can do that along it's
more that's more of a Consulting kind of
position okay so that doesn't require
you're in charge you're in charge of
your time did you get did you get what
you wanted to hear cuz we're telling you
the truth well we think is the truth I
think you should absolutely do it okay
but I would strike out on my own path
unless the hospital gives me the
flexibility cuz the flexibility is the
issue not the financial issue right okay
all right thanks so much awesome thank
you hey I I got to tell you I love love
love seeing single moms Jade just do
stuff that just I'm making life happen
taking care of the kiddos five kids five
kiddos my goodness I'm exhausted right
now just thinking about what she has to
do and yet she's doing it with a smile
on her face I know right Melissa you're
awesome thank you I think you inspired a
lot of ladies thanks for sharing that
story all right hey we got to do a quick
break but we're not done Jade
warshaw is my co-host I'm Ken Coleman
and this is the Ramy show don't
[Music]
[Applause]
move
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Jade warshaw is with me this
hour triple
8825 5225 is the number to jump in our
scripture of the day comes from Proverbs
2528 a man without self-control is like
a city broken into and left without
walls and our quote today from the
country music legend uh passed away uh
today I believe it was is when it was
reported Toby Keith who once said don't
compromise even if it hurts to be
yourself so if I had a Solo Cup I would
hold it up uh because he had some great
songs and I walking pillow talking come
on now I'm I love co-hosting with you we
need a music segment where it's kind of
like Name That Tune something like that
with Jade because she can sing anything
she can sing the foone ball how do you
like me now there she goes folks I'm on
my way yeah there wow this is great Toby
Keith fans are getting a little sold y'
didn't know that I knew I know about it
she knows she knows all right let's go
to Jessica in Orlando Florida Jessica
how can we help hi happy birthday Jade
thank you Jessica we're gonna celebrate
Jade the entire month of February it's
gonna be great exactly month long what's
up um so I was calling because um I kind
of need some advice um me and my husband
just got married last year in September
working really hard on trying to be you
know um faithful in our money and
keeping a budget it's all kind of new um
we have prop or I have land that I um
own and I'm trying to build a house
there um we are currently renting and so
I keep getting this pressure cuz we're
both a little bit older I'm 41 he's 38
and a lot of people are saying you know
we should really buy a house now well
it's not their life
right I know and so um I really want to
build this house because I feel like it
would be like the best um financially
and investing in our future um but I'm
also like really worried because I don't
know um accumulating the debt of the
building a house versus buying a house
really scares me neither of us have ever
like purchased um or like our homeowners
or anything like that just new foreign
grounds and own the land you already own
the land I already own the land yes
what's what did you pay for it or what's
it
worth um it's worth right now about 100,
70 to 100,000 based off of the taxes
that I'm getting charged um but I
actually purchased it from my parents
for less than like 2,000 oh wow okay so
it's worth a th 100,000 you bought it
for 2,000 correct okay and what would it
cost I mean have you done your research
what would it cost to build a home on it
I mean are you trying to spend 300,000
what are you trying to spend so I've
already gotten like a designer to build
like the blueprints and stuff and still
working with like different companies to
um do the construction papers and things
like that so we've been working on that
trying to do it slowly because we're
trying to pay it off each time we do it
and it does cost um money to get those
things done um but is looking like the
house that we are wanting to build can
be anywhere between 300,000 to 400,000
okay A couple of years ago they were
saying it was more towards like 500
600,000 because of how crazy the um cost
of supplies were but um it's going down
yeah so you're renting right now do you
have any other
debt um I have uh my student loans that
I've gotten down to about 7,000 okay and
I just have one credit card that's about
2,000 that's basically it what about
your husband nope he has no debt we zero
debt really have to get rid of that very
good and what do you um what do you earn
between the two of
you so I make about 880,000 and he makes
about 50 to 60,000 okay so here's here's
the parameters that I I would give you I
would first like and this is in order of
this is in order of priority what you do
first second third fourth first um I'm
going to pay off this de do you have any
money saved I didn't ask that sorry do
you have any money saved yes how much
yes we have um like the $1,000 emergency
fund okay and um I have some like
savings um like as a cushion in like a
separate account um it's like three or
4,000 and and then I have like my
um 401 and like I have a couple of like
stocks that I've like done as a child
and haven't really ever touched it it's
just like all sitting there so you've
got the 401K we're never touching that
until it's time in retirement what's in
the
stocks um it's I want to say it was like
40,000 I think okay I honestly sorry I
said great that's great I would check it
and just see what it's grown and what
look at it because I'm going to use it
so here's what I would do if I were in
your shoes today Jessica I would take
the 4,000 that I have saved aside from
baby step one and I would pay off the
credit card and then I would take the
other 2,000 and throw it at the student
loan and now you've only got a $5,000
student loan and then I would cash out
these stocks and be prepared for the
taxes because you're going to pay
something on them um and I'm going to
knock out the rest of that student loan
so now you're completely debt free and
you have $30,000 let's say and then I'm
going to set that $30,000 aside and call
that 3 to six months of expenses and
then from there we're going to work and
work and we're going to save up so that
we can start this construction to
permanent loan and that's the type of
loan that I'd want you to get on this um
because you want to make sure that the
construction is funded and then that
money rolls over into like a a real
mortgage so you want to do it the right
way there's been times where I've seen
people try to do it separate and do a
construction loan first and then turn
around and try to turn it into a
mortgage and they have issues and they
end up having to close more than once
and it's just more and more expensive so
try to look for a construction to
permanent loan that does it all with one
close closing that's what I would do um
and then the point the the the goal that
you're looking for in spending on this
build and on this mortgage is you don't
want it to be any more than 25% of your
take-home pay that's what we're getting
to so you've got to make sure that
you're really on this you create a very
clear budget you know what you can spend
and that's what it is and they're only
you know the plan is only spending what
you can afford to spend on this house
building it and so that's what you're
looking for 15 year fixed
rate okay I guess I have to calculate
what that um monthly bill would look
like if for what we can afford that's
exactly right and we've got a great uh
mortgage calculator for that so if you
go to ramseys solutions.com um and you
know or type just Google Ramsey
Solutions mortgage calculator you'll
find it and you can figure out okay like
what does this look like you know what
do I have to put up front in order to
make this happen and I think you guys
are on your way it might end up being
300,000 instead of 00,000 it just
depends on how long you guys want to
save and I I think this is a key Point
Jessica you you have to determine a a
realistic timeline based on the
financial advice that Jay gave you
because you're going to really really
regret it if you don't take that advice
the idea here is is when can we build
the house not if and I think you've got
to change that narrative if is not the
issue it's when you will be able to do
it so if it's an extra year fine so one
of the things I just want to point out
is that there is this notion in America
that renting is throwing money away have
you ever heard that oh yeah yeah but
it's not let me tell you why it's not in
your situation based on the context that
Jade just gave you it's not throwing
money away it's it's giving you
options as opposed to being
overleveraged with debt and stressed out
you started the call I could feel the
stress on you just thinking about the
idea of building a home so so why
wouldn't you take the option of renting
which is safety no risk in renting do
you see it that way
now yeah absolutely I think that there's
just a lot of pressure like yeah it was
a little bit less when I wasn't married
now that I'm married um there's just a
lot more pressure applied like when are
you going to have children when are you
going to have a home let me address that
okay because we only got 30 seconds I
want you to choose today you don't have
to do it on this phone call but I want
you to choose today before you go to bed
tonight which pressure do I want to deal
with do I want to deal with the pressure
of family and friends to do what they
want me to do or do I want to deal with
the pressure of bone crushing
debt those are two types of pressures
I'll take the pressure from family and
friends Jade all day long I don't want
the pressure of debt that I can't handle
that's true so it's a real Clear Choice
great hour Jade thanks for hanging out
as always James child's our fearless
leader and the the merry men in the
booth thank you for keeping us on the
air this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
oh